e
like to open up our longrange Capital
planning utilization committee I love
our new title
um and
um we should probably start with um
attendance if we could
we already we're all set with that set
forance okay for the minutes all right I
acting
I'll okay so we have minutes distributed
meeting motion motion by Pearl to to
move to accept any is there a
second any okay any corrections
omissions anything else else
necessary seeing none if you're in in
favor of uh acceptance of the minutes of
January 26 uh 2024 signified by saying I
I and opposed motion carries an
two all right let's uh let's move into
new
business
um l RP
lrcp uh 24 number six Department of
Health and Human Services request
approval for a 10-year lease uh with the
Northampton Boys 3
LLC uh for continued occupation of
approximately
15,879 square fet of office space
located at 109 Key Road in Keen for the
Department's Keen district office
effective April 1st 2024 end date March
31st
2034 for a lease cost of uh was that
$3,564
th000 uh subject to the conditions is
specified in request uh dated uh March
12th
2024 and
presenting please welcome to public
works good morning Mr chairman and
committee my name is Tammy Nelson I'm
the director of facilities for the
Department of Health and Human
Services I'm seeking authorization to
enter into a 10-year lease with
Northampton Boys 3 LLC which is the
current landlord for continued occupancy
of 109 Key Road in Keen this lease or
location provides for our Keen district
office serving clients in chesher County
the location has served the department
well operationally for staff providing a
secure and efficient Flor plan and for
the clients we serve
the facility is wellmaintained easily
accessible fully ADA Compliant and
provides ample
parking as outlined in our request we
were able to negotiate a favor favorable
rate structure the current square foot
rate is
$22 the rate is going to remain flat for
years one through five of the new term
with a 4.12% increase in year six the
new square foot rate of 2290 1 will be
in place for years 6 through 10 for the
total of
3,564
th000 the square foot rate includes all
utilities uh heating fuel electricity
water sewer insurance taxes um all site
maintenance all building repairs and
janitorial services this lease mirrors
the Department's practices in terms of
duration and full growth
structure your consideration
is greatly appreciated thank
you uh
questions I'm I'm not familiar with with
the building that you have been in and
will continue to occupy are you the only
tenant in that building it is a
multi-tenant building um single level so
there are other tenants I don't believe
there are any other state tenants in
that location
okay any further questions yes Senator p
good morning thanks for coming good
morning how long have you been in this
building prior to this we have been in
this building since 2013 which is was a
result of an RFP process and no issues
with the the LLC or other tenants no
thank
you repr Mills uh thank you thank you
for taking my question I I pardon my
ignorance on the total DHHS but are all
these other bureaus that are in there uh
sub subsidiaries of
DHHS for instance Bureau of elderly and
Adult Services divisions for children
Youth and Family Services those are
actually programs within the Department
of Health and Human Services okay so
there wouldn't be any reason to go back
to those departments looking for to
yeah um Mo motion made by Pearl seconded
by Mills uh to approve uh item number
006 Department of Health and Human
Services uh any further
discussion seeing none um if you're in
favor of the motion for the acceptance
of item number six uh signified by
saying I I any opposed any abstain thank
you thank you very much
could you uh just I I was looking
through the packet could could someone
just pull together a little uh snapshot
of me of the building and uh possibly
how many tenants are occupying it total
square footage not not now but ahead of
okay you just send along an outline of
the building a snapshot I'd be happy
thank you I'll find it on a trip
someday okay I'd like to move on to item
number
two uh which is um lrcp 24 item number
nine Department of
Transportation authorization to sell 1.
4 Acres of state owned land located the
corner of uh looks I think it's Smith
Road and ranburn
Street uh redb Street city of Manchester
directly to torington properties for
83,1 which includes of 1,100
administrative fee subject to the
conditions is specified in the request
dated March 14
2024 welcome thank you Mr chairman um
for the record my name is Steve leine
I'm the administrator of the Bureau of
RightWay within the Hampshire Department
of
Transportation um as you just said the
department requests authorization to
sell 1
Point 04 plus or minus acres of
state-owned land located at the corner
of Smith Road and radburn Street in the
city of Manchester to torington
properties for the price of $83,400
which includes the
$1,100 administrative fee the parcel was
acquired in
1974 for the construction and relocation
of New Hampshire Route One um New
Hampshire route 28a also known as
Mammoth Road for the Manchester hooks at
I 93 project from beis and WRR Jim Rose
for the sum of $3,000 via warranty deed
the parcel will be con as as conditions
of the sale uh the B buyer must
commissioned a licensed land surveyor in
the state of New Hampshire to prepare a
boundary line survey
which will be recorded in the Hillsboro
County registry
AED and a uh copy of which will also be
provided to the department the buyer
shall be responsible for all local and
state land use approvals um buyer will
be made fully aware of all Federal
Aviation Administration reporting
requirements for any future construction
due to the sit's proximity to Manchester
Boston Regional Airport and uh a staff
appraiser from the department has
determined that as of January 11th
2024 um the value of the the value of
the property is
82,000 uh the department will solicit
interest from the city of Manchester in
the Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
prior to closing I can answer any
questions thank you questions Mr Lamonte
yes Senator Pearl thank you for coming
in this morning just looking at the map
here and it looks like rador radb Street
I guess it is and Smith Road that
intersection is kind of in an obscure
angle is there is there any concern that
down the road the the state may have an
interest in fixing that corner a bit I'm
just curious you know with selling the
property what kind of lose that option
to do so what I can say is is that when
this request came in it was run through
our Bureau of Highway design and also
our local um uh District 5 uh
maintenance District um the both the
engineers weighed in from those two
bureaus and they didn't have any
concerns with the disposal of property
thank you which is our typical practice
great thank you further
question seeing none do we have a motion
on item uh
09 I'll second that Mo to approve item
24-9
okay okay thank you okay all right um
any any discussion amongst the
members seeing none if you're in favor
of uh approving item 009 Department of
Transportation authorizing selling 1.02
acres of land city of Manchester
directly to torington property signified
by saying I I I if you're opposed nay
seeing none motion carries
unanimously so would you like to move on
to item uh 01 3 Department of
Transportation authorized to Grant
access point through the limited access
right of way on the southerly side of
New Hampshire route
1111 at Fry Road in the town of Danville
to the town of Danville for the sale
price of
53,500 which includes the one $11,100
administrative fee subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
dated March 20th 202 for if you would
sir thank you Mr chairman uh the limited
access right of way was created uh was
laid out in um with the layout of New
Hampshire Route 111 through by the
Hamstead Danville Kingston project in
1968 uh upon completion so just just a
little background for the committee when
the department goes through and conducts
a project involving limited access right
of way when they go through an acire all
the property rights one of the property
rights the uh property owner is
compensated for is the right of access
so they no longer have any access rights
to the new road which in this case was
New Hampshire
111 um so in in this point in this case
uh this project had been going on for
probably or it's kind of been in the
works with the town also involved for
approximate well probably more than 15
years there was a um there was some
interest in doing it uh like around 2010
2011 but the developer lost funding at
that point they were working with the
town um and uh again just more recently
they have a new developer so the um the
project as I just mentioned the Danville
Kingston project um involved um the
completion New Hampshire Route 11
Huntington Hill Road and then bisected
Huntington Hill Road um and created Fry
Road to the south of Route 111 however
there was no access so there was no it's
not like there was an intersection
of Fry Road and New Hampshire Route 11
there will be an access point so that's
basically what they're creating Now by
doing this project and this will a
actually
allow uh development to one of the abing
partials okay if if I could so
um if I understood and correct me if I'm
wrong so this property originally uh was
part of a limited access Highway the
rights were were paid for by the state
in essence to remove access compensate
them for not having more than whatever
access point uh time the calendar moves
forward and now they need access onto
the limited on is it still limited
access Highway where we're going on to
it correct as it stands today it is uh
Route 111 through that area is a limited
access right away if we are to if we
grant them this break in that limited
access this will allow the development
of an intersection at that point which
will allow further development of an
abutting par and I and I fully
understand it's somewhat unusual but I I
agree with the premise so if if this is
agreed to and the purchase price with
the appraisal is agreed to then do then
will grant access onto that section of
road that is correct all right thank you
further
questions seeing
none uh if you're in uh do we have a
motion to be to accept this Mr chair I'm
I move we
2413 second that
okay motion made by clud or seconded by
Mills uh any further
discussion if you're in favor of
acceptance of item number 013 Department
of Transportation
$53,500 plus appraisal Administration
fees signified by saying I I any opposed
unanimously okay we'll move to item
number 14 Department of
Transportation uh authorization to sell
4.7 Acres of state owned land located in
the southernly side of New Hampshire
route 302 Eastman Road in the town of
Conway directly to the abutter Byer
kennet for
941,618
administrated fee subject conditions
specified in the request dated March
21st 202 before and if you would Mr
lonte take us through thank you Mr
chairman uh the original uh parcel which
was 6.28 Acres um was acquired in 1999
through condemnation from Francis Sterns
kenet revokable trust at the time of the
acquisition the department as I just
said had acquired the 6.28 acres for 2.2
uh for
2,289 th000
uh prior to for for an out of court
settlement that's what the final price
was uh the department is retaining 1.5
Acres of uh for a detention Pond which
will serve New Hampshire route uh I
think it's US Route 302 in that area um
so we will then be conveying back
conveying back uh 4.7 Acres uh as a
conditions of this sale the land survey
uh buyer will have to have a land
surveyor pred prepare a perimeter
boundary line uh survey which will be
recorded in the Caroll County registry
of deeds um buyer will be responsible
for all local and state land use
approvals before closing and the uh
staff appraiser from the Department
looked at the partial to be conveyed and
determined as of February 5th 2024 had
it had a value of
900,000 um
940,000 I have the same problems yeah
thank you uh
questions um I I have a question um the
uh the one plus acres it's being
retained for the detention pond at
302 uh will that be for the sole purpose
purpose of that or will this parcel also
be able to access that
drainage uh I'm not sure what the
developers plans are right now they
would typically have to come to us if
they have an interest that's not
included as a condition of this sale and
we're and we're keeping that in fee
that's not just a drainage okay thank
you any further
questions uh just for the um committee
this is this is part this is adjacent to
a very large project that's taking is
going to be going on for several years
and it's it's important to the area also
so um do we have a motion for item uh
number 14 move to
approve move by Mills seconded by Pearl
uh any discussion on the
motion uh motion is to accept
authorization to sell for points 7 Acres
settling side of 302 town of Conway uh
for
$941,000 if you're in favor of that
motion is signified by saying I I I and
unanimously and we will move to item
number 15 Department of Transportation
authorization to sell six Parcels
compromised properly 7 .2 acres of
state-owned land on New Hampshire Route
16 and US Route
302 uh in the town of Conway directly to
the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority uh for
1,5 $11,100 which includes the
administration fee of
$1,100 subject to the conditions request
dated March 21st 2024 and if you would
sir
thank you Mr chairman
um this parcel sits directly north of
the Memorial Hospital in the town of
Conway uh it originally was comprised of
six Parcels it's now down for tax
purposes been reduced down to six um uh
to four
Parcels um the the six Parcels was
originally
acquired um between the years of 1997 in
2006 for the Conway bypass for a total
of
$852,500
um
this this property will be conveyed with
the following conditions um the buyer
will be required to have a licensed land
surveyor uh survey the property and
create a boundary line survey buyer will
be responsible to um for all local and
state land use approvals uh they'll be
accepted in reserve from this conveyance
a 30f foot access point to um which will
serve one of the um an access easement
because just of the shape of the parcel
it has this long sliver that goes along
Route 16 um which will be which will be
for the use of the hospital
um and it'll be accepting and reserving
all current slope and drainage easements
and uh there are two also utility
current utility easements will be
accepted and reserved the staff
appraiser from the Department evaluated
the property and as of um September 12th
2023 uh it was determined to
be um 1
Point
1,510 ,000 was the value uh the property
has already been offered to the town and
it is being bued by the uh New Hampshire
Housing Finance it is being purchased by
the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority has already been offered to
the town and they are on board with the
project I believe it's going to be used
for the idea here the intent is that
it'll be used for Workforce
housing thank you
questions so I'm I'm assuming that if I
could sir that the uh that the money
that's raised here the $1.5 million is
being being given back to the feds as
part of the monies that we owe them for
this property it has uh my understanding
it has already been given back to the
feds and this will be used to backfill
okay U motion Ager to accept uh item
number 15 is there a second second um
did you have
questions okay um so Mo motion is to
authorize item number
15 town of Conway um excuse me New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority uh
$1,511
subject to the conditions specified in
March 21st
2024 if you're in favor of that motion
You signifi by saying I I any opposed
unanimous next item uh item uh
24007 Department of administrative
Services authorized to enter the use of
premise agreement with the county of
Coos uh West Stewarts Town for leasing
of state owned property located Coos
County Superior Courthouse located at 55
School Street Lancaster New Hampshire
from June 1st
2024 to May 31st 2027 for the amount not
to exceed uh
25,39 to subject to the conditions is
specified in the request dated February
2024 welcome good morning uh my name is
Sarah Lineberry and I'm the
superintendent of the Bureau of Court
facilities thank you chairman and
committee um we are here today um as per
our letter of request um to seek
approval to lease space at the Coos uh
County Courthouse to the county for the
uh uh for the county attorney's office
registry of deeds and the Sheriff's
Office the court does not need the space
and the rental income covers operating
expenses also the adjacency is
beneficial to daily Core Business I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
lanberry seeing
none uh motion by Senator Pearl to
approve item uh 007 Department of
administrative Services second seconded
by
Mills um for the amount not to exceed
25,39 to uh conditions specify the
request dated February 28 24 if you're
in favor of that motion is signified by
saying I I oppose nay motion carries
unanimously thank you thank
you we will now proceed to item number
16 Department of trans excuse me
Department administrative service
authorized to retroactively enter into
use of premac this agreement town of
Jaffrey uh 10
good now Street Jeffrey for leasing
estate owned property located Jeffrey
Circuit Courthouse 84 Peterborough
Street Jeffrey from November 1 of 2023
to October 31
2026 for the amount not to exceed
$1,852 subject to conditions specify the
request dated March 11
2024 please again um we are seeking to
approve the Retro active lease at the
Jaffrey circuit court and this is to the
town of Jaffrey for um the space for the
prosecutor the court does not need the
space um the rental income covers our
operating expenses and the adjacency um
for all entities is beneficial in the
courthouse thank you questions The
Madam seeing none do I have a motion Mr
shair yes I move that uh we approve
should be retroactively I don't that's
matter the motion item
24-1 thank you moot motion made by clud
your seconded by Senator Pearl um any
further discussion seeing none if you're
in favor of the motion you'll signify
this is item number
16 uh for the amount of
$2,852 you'll signify by saying I I I
any opposed seeing none motion carries
unanimously
much we will uh disposal of uh real
estate uh lrp lrcp keep trying to say
the Lakes Region Planning Commission
apologize uh item
24011 Department of
Transportation uh authorization to lease
approximately 64 Acres consisting of
portions of three contiguous parcels
State on chesher Branch Railroad
Corridor Town Swansea uh for allpurpose
storage uh for $900 per year with a
one-time administrative fee of ,00 of
which the department is in receipt of
500 for a period of five years with an
option for an additional five years at
$900 per year subject to conditions
specified in the request dated March 11
2024 welcome please uh continue good
morning chairman makoni Senator Pearl
Representatives Edgar miltz and cler my
name is Lewis Barker I am the railroad
planner for the Department of
transportations Bureau of rail and
Transit I speak to you about a proposed
lease on the uh long abandoned chesher
uh Branch Railroad Corridor to
allpurpose
storage there's um property that they're
going to use for uh basically storage
they were viewshed maintenance a fence
all in cooperation with the town of
Swansea um to make
uh a commercial site attractive and
Avail parking for trail users um on the
uh on the current uh rail trail any
questions I'll be glad to answer thank
you are there any questions Mr Barker
seeing none uh do I have a motion on
item uh
011 move to approve sir motion by Mills
edar um so if you're in favor of the
motion to uh authorize item number
011 uh which is leasing of property at
the price is shown and request uh
the request that was dated March 11 2024
signified by saying I
I any opposed motion carries
unanimous item uh number 12 Department
of trans Transportation authorized to
sell approximately
18,900 square fet or 043 Acres on
state-owned Berlin Branch Railroad
Corridor in the town of Littleton to
rail trail properties llc's and a butter
for
$1,400 in
$1100 administrative fee for which the
department is in receipt of $500 subject
to the conditions is specified in
request dated March 18
2024 Mr Barker
please this proposed uh sale is for a
strip of land adjacent to a former
Factory building that has been
repurposed as a
residential uh Community uh the former
uh
Factory was built right on the the
property line because the railroad cars
were actually brought up right there to
a loading dock that is long gone um the
town of uh Littleton needs the uh access
uh for emergency vehicles so the uh
developer came to us and requested to
purchase this strip of land um and we U
feel it's an appropriate use of the land
we do not want to man manage it as a
lease um so this is why we propose a
sale right other questions Mr
Barker yes please Senator Pearl thank
you thanks for coming in today was was
this formally just like a rail siding
for that that service that yes there was
a s in there at one time tracks are
removed long ago unfortunately yes thank
you all right any further
questions do I have a motion to
authorize item 0 one two Department of
Transportation moved by Senator Pearl
second by
Mills um so the motion is to authorize
sell approximately
18,900 Square ft 043 Acres of state
owned Berlin Branch Corridor town of
Littleton to the rail trail properties
for a price of um $11,400 plus
administrative fees subject to the
request dated March 18
2024 if you're in favor of that motion
you'll signify by saying I I I any
opposed motion carries
unanimously thank you we will move on to
item number 010 Department of
Transportation request uh approval to
enter a one-year lease uh for sun Lake
Village Association for
375 linear feet of RA of railroad
Frontage along Lake wnpa
winnisquam to allow private
non-commercial dock including a
pedestrian acrade Crossing on the S at
on the state owned conquered to Lincoln
railroad Corridor in the town of Belmont
13,113 75 per year plus a $50 annual fee
for the private pedestrian at grade
75 plus 1,00 administrative fee subject
to the conditions as specified in the
request dated March 6
2024 and if you would Mr
Barker yes the state has been approached
by the representatives of the sun Lake
Village Association requesting
Waterfront
access um they qualify on the basis of
that subdivision and development was
commenced at least 20 years ago I have a
time frame of between 2001 and 2004 in
my
notes uh this um is advantageous to us
because multiple houses qualify and
we're going to restrict them to one
Crossing which minimizes the safety uh
concerns we have with any
Crossings all right yes rep excuse me
Senator Pearl I tried to bring you back
to the house there for a moment some
days I wouldn't mind that please
continue so this is a one-year lease yes
uh the statute uh requires us to update
the uh annual fee every five years and
this is at the end of that five-year
period so we uh feel it's best to go
with a one-year lease and negotiate a uh
well actually calculate the new uh rate
based on the Consumer Price Index so uh
we'll be back with these people with a
new lease with a better with a higher
price with the because the CPI is not
looking like it's going down anytime
soon okay thank you that answered my
second question yeah thank you thank you
further questions Mr
Barker uh seeing none do we have a
motion uh for the approval of item
number
010 Mr chair I move approval of item
24-10 all right thank you uh motion by
cluder seced by
Mills uh is there any
discussion if you're in favor of the
motion um to request the approval of
item uh 2410 Department of
Transportation allow private
non-commercial dock including a
pedestrian at grade crossing a state
owned conquered Lincoln railroad town of
Belmont for proposed lease uh per year
of $1
13,113 75 plus a $50 annual fee for
private pedestrian acrade Crossing uh
under the conditions specify the request
dated March 6 2024 you'll signify by
saying I I any opposed uh no oppos
unanimously I believe that is our
business I we have in your packet
informational uh from Department of
resources and development uh minutes um
I would like to um schedule our next
meeting for June 10th for 10 o'clock for
this long range Capital planning
utilization committee uh is there any
other business that needs to be
discussed at this
time I want to thank you all for your
attendance we need a motion to motion to
adjourn motion to adjourn I'll second
that okay all in favor of adjourn